in in Europe in particular but America
as well have made two massive
miscalculations that are generational
the first is we have massively
underestimated number of people who want
to come and in sub-Saharan Africa alone
that is just a bottomless number of
people so we have massively
underestimated the number of people who
want to come into our countries and we
are massively overestimated our ability
to integrate them it's a joke this is
what I realized when I first was on lab
producer it's a joke to think that these
people are going to soon become Milanese
Italians or Florentine Italians and it's
a joke they woke their lives will be
very miserable in Italy they will be in
a criminal underclass gang world where
at best they will be selling illegal
handbags on bridges in Venice and
running from the police the idea that
this is the next generation of Europeans
is for the birds